hey what's up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
today I'm going to be taking a look at
two of the highest end phones available
right now the Samsung Galaxy Note 2 and
the samsung galaxy s3 the note 2 has
been likened to sort of a stretched-out
or even a supercharged galaxy s3 there
are a few similarities between the two
phones and a few differences between the
phones so without any further ado let's
go ahead and take a look at them the
biggest difference between these two
phones is the galaxy s3 is a four point
eight inch display and the Galaxy Note 2
is a 5.5 inch display that right there
that form-factor difference is the
biggest difference between these two
phones but there are a few small
hardware differences between the two
first of all the sensors and the
front-facing camera and the notification
light on the front of the note are in a
slightly different placement than on the
s3 but that doesn't really affect
anything but if you check out the back
here they both have a very clean look of
course and they have the exact same
camera and camera placement so they take
the same quality eight megapixel photos
and 1080p videos but the speaker on the
note is much better it's in a different
placement down at the bottom and it's a
much bigger louder clearer speaker than
the speaker on the galaxy s3 so that's
great for media consumption and of
course the note has more room inside so
that makes for a massive 3100 milliamp
power battery which is much bigger than
the 2100 milli ampere in the galaxy s3
and this is one of the biggest buying
points of the note like I mentioned in
the review which is linked right down
below like button on this video so
basically if you want a phone that can
last you an entire weekend road trip or
something if you forget your charger the
note will last you it's got to be the
note both of these phones are still
pretty thin though in their own respects
they have similar form factors the
galaxy s3 feels a little bit more curved
though because of the way the back fits
on the front but if you like that look
of the note you might go with the square
look instead but they both are also
pretty pocketable so obviously the note
is a little bit more noticeable in your
pocket but there are no problems here
with portability the hardware inside
these phones is insane the United States
versions of the galaxy s3 rocks a
dual-core processor the Snapdragon s4
and the note 2 is rocking
core processor and they both have two
gigs of RAM and LTE in the United States
so no performance issues with any of
these apps run smooth games run smooth
browsing runs quickly everything's
snappy the biggest software difference
is that the note 2 has jellybean out of
the box while the galaxy s3 is still
waiting for that update
right now it has Ice Cream Sandwich for
now and another way these devices defer
besides their physical size is the
unique S Pen Stylus
for the galaxy note this stylus is
unique in a couple of ways it integrates
with TouchWiz to provide some added
features is just as responsive as your
fingers on the screen and you can even
use it to take some head writing notes
with handwriting recognition so it's all
around really quite useful whether you
decide to take advantage of it or not
but all of this stuff the stylus stuff
definitely establishes the note 2 as a
two-handed device and that brings us
right back to the size again because
this all hinges on the difference in
these displays the galaxy s3 like we
mentioned earlier is a four point eight
inch display 1280 by 720 resolution and
Super AMOLED panel rocking a pentile sub
pixel matrix which is a it's bigger than
average it's a pretty large for a
smartphone and I happen to be able to
reach all four corners with one hand
while using it but not everyone can but
the point is the Galaxy Note 2 is
rocking a 5.5 inch monster display of
that same 720p resolution and that Super
AMOLED technology but it's not pentile
which means things look just as sharp
despite the slightly lower pixel density
all that bigger screen just gives you
more room to play with the galaxy s3 and
other smaller devices you'll notice that
while you're gaming you have your thumbs
on the screen and while you're at the
controls your thumbs will take up a good
portion of the display you can only
really concentrate on the portion right
in between your thumbs right in the
center between your thumbs is where the
game is on that boss display on the
Galaxy Note you don't have to worry
about missing any of the content you can
see it's almost all viewable it's all
there even with your thumbs there on the
screen on the outside so here's a little
size difference to scale it all out
galaxy s3 galaxy note galaxy s3 note s3
Note S 3 note s3 note yeah you get
so there you go guys there's obviously a
lot to like about both of these devices
but honestly I want to know which one
would you pick if you had the choice
between the two now I've had the galaxy
s3 for a while and I actually moved to
the galaxy note 2 for my testing and for
my review and I felt that the galaxy s3
was a great size but then I came back
from the huge note and the galaxy s3
actually seemed small which was
interesting so I'm still trying to get
used to the concept of thinking a 4.8
inch display on a phone is small but
anyway I mentioned hearing your thoughts
what do you guys think of the 5.5 inch
Galaxy Note 2 versus the 4.8 inch Galaxy
s3 in the United States what do you guys
what would you pick what would you
decide either way if you enjoy this
comparison video feel free to +1 or give
it a thumbs up on YouTube and if you
want to see more videos like this be
sure to subscribe by clicking that
subscribe button above on YouTube then
you'll be able to see all the more
videos that I put out in the next
upcoming weeks but either way thanks for
watching this one and I'll talk to you
guys in the next video
you